we should totally concede this obvious
point I don't know why this is a point
that has been made by some people that
we know that we need institutions we
need institutions that we can rely on
that we can trust um and we can't only
figure this out through substacks and
through this infinite Division and you
know all these different branches on
substack and podcast where everyone has
their hot takes on vaccines and all
these things that that that that's a
totally dysfunctional model right to
have this much division this many
infinite sources of
information hey folks welcome to the
Darkhorse podcast I am Dr Brett
Weinstein and I have the pleasure of
sitting this afternoon with RAV Aurora
who is an independent journalist and he
is part of the joint partnership called
illusion of consensus on substack with
Jay bataria Welcome To Dark Horse uh RAV
hey Brett it's great to be here awesome
so um you and I have been talking
informally over the course of many
months on a number of different
topics and um you impressed upon me that
some of these topics needed a wider
exploration for example here on
Darkhorse so let's talk first about how
it is that you find yourself in
journalism and then we'll get to some of
the topics that uh you and I find uh
jointly interesting sure sure so just to
paint a broad picture I graduated in
2019 and didn't know what the I was
doing with my life um and was very
creative into writing into reading into
debating and looking at things
critically and then BLM happened in 2020
the George Floyd tragedy and there I saw
a big vacuum in mainstream media and
covering these events honestly um and so
I started writing about uh I identity
politics and white privilege claims
about systemic racism group
disparities and particularly police
shootings and inner city violence and
put out a couple of big pieces that I I
had no idea what I was getting into but
they ended up doing really really well a
lot of people saw it at the time um a
lot of people in the formerly
intellectual dark web kind of circulated
in those in those groups and after being
quite successful at about identity
politics and criminal justice and police
violence in particular in the New York
Post quette and the globe in mail
primarily I just kept on going on that
path and writing more and more doing
podcasts and long do you want to do you
want to just summarize for people in the
audience who may not be familiar with
that work um what was the General tenor
of your exploration of uh the social
justice scene yeah sure yeah this
actually relates to some of the co stuff
is the perception on a lot of these hot
button topics like police violence like
racial
disparities was very different from what
was actually going on right if you pull
liberals and progressives on how
many on how many black men are killed as
a result of police violence how many uh
black men are the victims of of police
shootings you find that the people
surveyed in these polls their estimates
are 10x 100x more than what the actual
number often is and so there's this vast
disparity in perceptions and reality and
that's a very interesting topic to
explore because you have the media
that's participating in this kind of
gaslighting and this exaggeration of the
the statistics and mentioning of the
statistics would often get you cancelled
or be quite controversial and so that
was kind of an area that I was I was
talking about was that what the
mainstream media is presenting and what
politicians and liberal activists are
saying on this front is very different
from what's actually going on and as
we'll get into with the co stuff the
only reason why I was able to succeed on
that front was because there was a
serious problem with how journalism was
being conducted and there was a big room
for someone like myself a 20-year-old
nobody to come in and say something that
a lot of other journalists weren't
saying now obviously I wasn't the only
one there's guys like Coleman Hughes who
I've kind of followed a little bit in
their footsteps but there was a clear
space to talk honestly about these
things when you can't trust the New York
Times the way you could have a few years
ago on some of these topics and that
directly leads into the co stuff as well
yes uh I did want to point out I I think
it will be um an interesting
Counterpoint to things that may come up
here later
but I thought one of the best
explorations of this that I encountered
in that time was actually by Sam Harris
who I'm sure you remember the podcast
that he did in which he went
painstakingly through the statistics and
compared them to people's beliefs and
expectations on this topic and it was
absolutely Stark the distinction between
what people thought was going on and
what's actually going on Absol which
then suggests that we live in an
environment in which people's beliefs
can become Paramount above and beyond
reality and it can motivate you know
social movements for example which is a
frightening prospect it's exactly the
kind of thing right um that you would
want reliable institutions to prevent by
saying as much as we may suspect X the
truth is really why that's an important
role to play and it's interesting that
many of
um the institutions you would have
expected to play that role instead
through gasoline on the fire and just
simply Amplified people's uh people's uh
distortions right and interesting on
that example and I absolutely condemn I
condemned Sam at the or commended Sam at
the time for what he did and that was
excellent but interesting on that
example like the BLM stuff and police
violence the quote unquote expert class
on that topic was was and is completely
wrong right and that expert class
doesn't include Glenn Lowry John mcarter
who are also very sophisticated
intellectuals Thomas soul but that
expert class of Michael Eric Dyson um
Iber X kendi tanasi
coats um you know I mean I mean take
your pick I mean go go to any Elite
College University and things like white
privilege systemic racism they being an
epidemic of police violence is in their
sociology journals it's it's absolutely
institutionalized as these kind of
truths on Race that someone like Sam at
the time and myself and others were
questioning and saying hey these chosen
gurus on race and slavery and the legacy
of racism these guys are wrong and that
and that's respectable when you look at
what the experts are saying and
recognize that they're wrong and here's
actually what's what's what's really
going on and the bravery and courage
that comes with questioning the experts
on a given
topic yeah it's uh it's a pattern
that uh I think we can see readily
across many topics at the moment but
it's really that there
are two kinds of experts there are
anointed experts and then there are off
label experts and the off Lael experts
are obviously going to be mixed in some
sense they're going to have a diversity
of opinions some of them maybe not so
great but the interesting feature of the
present as we EXP experience it is that
the anointed experts seem to be wrong
about everything it's uh it's a it's the
most remarkable fact there is and so you
know you named a good list of people who
were quite insightful on this topic as
it was happening um but you know somehow
they it's like they don't reflect in the
mirror our first sponsor for this
episode is the wellness company
world-renowned experts like Dr Peter
McCulla have partnered with the wellness
company to create real change in
healthcare they offer a wide variety of
supplements and services including T
Health and emergency medical kits
containing iroman and teams of medical
professionals that can assist in helping
patients kick the pharmaceutical habit
with their freedom from Pharma
program the wellness company has all
sorts of useful and important products
try their mitos support as in
mitochondria which is formulated to
provide energy both physical and mental
they also have Spike support formula
which is their most popular product it
is not only useful for those who have
been vac vaccinated but for anyone who
may be suffering from long coid as well
as the wellness company says on their
website if you're looking to get back to
that pre-co feeling their Spike support
formula can help Spike support is made
with a combination of natural
ingredients like ninas dandelion root
extract selenium black sativa extract
Irish sea moss and green tea extract
these ingredients all contain immune
boosting capabilities and the Nares
specifically has been used by the
Japanese for decades because of its
ability to dissolve blood clots but more
recently ninas has been shown to be able
to break down Spike protein in the
bloodstream and even block them from
binding to
cells Dr McCulla says out of all the
available therapies I've used in my
practice and among all the proposed
detoxification agents I believe ninas
and related peptides hold the greatest
promise for patients whether you've
taken the vaccine or just had coid if
you're concerned about circulating Spike
Pro proteins go to TWC Health Darkhorse
and use the code Darkhorse to save 15%
off your first order that's TW wc.
Health Darkhorse code Darkhorse to save
15% our second sponsor is Paleo Valley
paleo Valley makes a huge range of
products from supplements like fish row
and organ complex grass-fed bone broth
protein and superfood bars everything
we've tried from them has been terrific
including their golden milk which is
made with tons of turmeric but we're
going to talk today about beef sticks
the beef in these delicious snacks comes
from small American-owned Farms that
practice rotational grazing paleo
Valley's beef sticks are 100% grass-fed
and finished entirely organic and
naturally
fermented 100% grass-fed beef is more
nutritious than grain-fed beef in many
ways including that it contains more
calcium magnesium potassium zinc
phosphorus beta carotene and iron it's
also delicious if you're thinking that
paleo Valley's beef sticks are like slim
gyms you're wrong for one thing unlike
slim jyms paleo Valley beef sticks
contain no mechanically separated
chicken parts for another paleo Valley's
beef sticks are actually good for you
ingredients hiding in most beef sticks
and jerky include MSG hormones
hydrogenated oils and brominated
vegetable oil which if you're wondering
was first patented as a flame retardant
it's now in a lot of food but you won't
find it if you buy paleo Valley
furthermore online other meat snacks
paleo Valley uses natural fermentation
to preserve its beef sticks this gives
the beef sticks a long shelf life
without the use of harmful acids and
chemicals and with the added benefit of
contributing to a healthy gut paleo valy
beef Stacks are also keto keto-friendly
and make a great protein Rich snack to
grab when you are on the go like running
out the door for a meeting or going on a
bike ride paleo Valley doesn't cut
Corners either they Source only the
highest quality ingredients and are
passionate not only about human health
but also about environmental restoration
and Animal Welfare as well they are a
family-owned company try paleo Val's
beef sticks today you won't be sorry
head over to paleo
valley.com Darkhorse for 15% off your
first
order right the only experts that make a
difference are the ones that have been
uh almost ordained in some sacred order
in which they are allowed to hold forth
on a topic because we know what they're
going to say they're going to say
exactly what is necessary to reinforce
uh a suspicion the public has that may
be dead wrong right right and there's
different ways to get into the co stuff
but on on that on that front I think
it's important to say when it came to
expertise with BLM and the the way in
which that was conducted and now with
coid there's been I think a big
mistake among many people in podcast aan
and media alternative conservative like
doesn't matter which political
affiliation but there's been a big
mistake on the part of the public in
thinking that the experts in the
relevant areas in epidem epidemiology
and Immunology agree on the fundamental
points right that I think was a big big
mistake I mean you have a big spectrum
of experts Peter hotz Eric toppel
Nicholas christakis Martin korf Tracy
Beth hog vanai Pasad J bataria and then
you can go on you know Robert Malone
Peter McCulla etc etc you have this
interesting range and and even if you
want to put aside Malone Mulla we can
talk about them but even if you want to
put them aside and you only want to pick
you know experts at Stanford and Harvard
and our Elite universities and so you
end up with Jay Martin Marty McCary from
Hopkins Tracy Beth hog uh Dr laipo from
uh Harvard who's now Florida Surgeon
General it's like those guys and Eric
toppel Peter hotz Nicholas kakis many
people who
understandably I would have also
defaulted to potentially at the very
very start like Eric toppel Rock Solid
credentials Nicholas christakis great
respect for him before the pandemic and
at the start but those guys completely
disagreed with this other set of experts
on the most fundamental questions on
lockdowns on vaccine mandates on vaccine
safety right if you if you got those
people together in the room you would
find what Dr J bachari has to say or
Martin cuor has to say and Martin is one
of the foremost experts on vaccine
safety I mean if you really want to play
the the expert game there are some
people who are trained in vaccine safety
I'd put Martin um as one of the highest
people in that group they took a very
different line than Dr Eric toppel did
in terms of what's really going on with
vaccine injuries and and we can talk
about the specifics of that but I think
that's been a fundamental error is
grouping well the experts say this on
vaccines the experts say this on on
lockdowns it's like which
experts uh the anointed ones and and
that's really the point is that you will
be anointed if you say things that are
not discordant and there and you will be
sidelined and worse you will be
stigmatized as a what was the term with
Jay a fringe
epidemiologist um yeah you know it
doesn't matter what your credential is
that's that's the most remarkable
feature of all is that many of the
people who were stigmatized as Fringe
quacks are
at the top of their fields these are the
leaders the most insightful folks and
the point is nobody is immune from those
stigmas in the effort to create well you
know as your uh substack alludes to the
illusion of consensus and that that's
really what it is is if you're not on
message you will in one way be one way
or another you will be sidelined and
that will leave the impression that
there is Broad agreement and the only
way you would get to Broad agreement as
if it was obvious that something was
true so it results in the public that
doesn't know how this game is working
concluding quite incorrectly that there
is not a diversity of of opinion amongst
people who know what they're talking
about yeah yeah and this goes right back
to the start of the pandemic right like
how deadly is coid who's really at risk
the people that were chosen by the
Atlantic the New York Times
Etc were were of a certain type who were
saying things like I mean even down to
just 1% of people are dying of coid and
that was something Dr Nicholas Christus
was saying on Sam Harris's podcast as
late as late 2021 I believe that that
that was wrong that was wrong in like
summer of 2020 that was wrong in 20 in
2021 and and again if you want to play
the expert game someone like Dr J
bachara and Dr John yiis W in the most
credential cited people Dr John Unis who
was doing the surveys and analyses on
infection fatality rate and Dr Jay and
John at Stanford were authoring these
studies at the very very start and
finding that oh the number of people
that are actually infected with coid is
far bigger than what we thought
therefore the um the the denominator of
total people people infected is far far
bigger therefore the fatality rate is
far far lower than what we thought so it
wasn't 1% It Wasn't 2% they found I
believe early on 0.2% 0.1% with a very
sharp age gradient with very few like
almost not impossible but very very
difficult to find cases under 30 with no
comorbidities or you know even older
people with no comorbidities right and
those people were demonized from the
very very start for doing that research
whereas other people were looking at
other metrics and studies that didn't
take a proper account of how many people
were actually infected with coid and
therefore you have people you know like
Sam Harris reading the New York Times
trusting Nicholas Christus and hearing
oh what in 100 people are dying of coid
oh sh holy crap what 1% of people it's
like no no no that that's not actually
the reality it's actually far far lower
than that and years after the fact it is
now clear that a there was a systematic
statistical attempt to increase the
impression of lethality in the virus
that basically counting people who died
with coid but not of Co or even counting
people who didn't have Co at all as Co
deaths was a mechanism to create this
fear which caused us to overreact it's
really like the beasting that doesn't
kill you but the overreaction of your
immune system to it does but beyond that
there is also the jaw-dropping fact of
the protocols that were deployed for
those who were in dire need of help
because they had severe coid seems to
have killed an awful lot of people also
creating the impression that this was a
much deadlier disease than it actually
turned out to be so um I do not
know with any certainty how to read that
but one possible read is that something
wanted us terrified so that we would
allow a much more aggressive response to
this than we should have that we made Co
vastly more destructive in ways that are
both Direct by giving bad medical advice
uh as to what to do if you contracted
coid um but also lots of collateral
damage from the shutting down of
civilization um from uh the breaking of
normal developmental patterns in
children um the causing people to stay
indoors where the virus does spread
rather than go Outdoors where it doesn't
spread and where they would make vitamin
D which would make them safer
make them less likely to contract it and
more likely to survive it if they did
contract it so we did everything wrong
and it's possible that that was just the
most
mindblowing series of incompetent
decisions the universe has ever seen
where it's possible that actually
something wanted this to be worse than
it actually was because it had an
ulterior motive I I still don't know to
this day but it's hard for me to believe
incompetence could have gotten us here
and I guess the last thing I would
mention a list of people who were
heterodox when it came to social justice
who then fumbled the ball with respect
to coid and I find that a fascinating
pattern people who were perfectly
capable of standing up to a False
Consensus just in the case of coid
absolutely fell in line and got it all
wrong yes yeah um yeah there there's a
lot to be said there I mean it's you
know I I'm I'm inclined to just
default to
incompetence a lot of times but the
problem is a lot of mistakes can't
logically be chocked down to just
incompetence right you have January 2021
relle winsky emailing I believe um I'm
forgetting who else was in this email um
head of the
NIH at the time uh Collins Collins yeah
I believe Collins is in the email I
think fouchi might have been in the
email anyway she put out this email and
said oh we're hearing about breakthrough
cases can you please tell us more about
this we're realizing a lot of people who
um got the vaccine are still getting
coid right yet five six months later
MSNBC on CDC press releases saying you
get the vaccine and you become a dead
end to the virus it's like you knew
there was an issue there right same
thing with myocarditis right in um want
to say March or April of
2021 same same official CDC relle
wilinsky says we've looked at millions
of cases of of uh vaccine Administration
and this concern of of myocarditis we've
looked at it carefully and we haven't
found a serious statistically
significant risk on that front later on
they backtrack and say oh well actually
there is a concern but you know the risk
of of coid outweighs uh myocarditis
which is honestly so so wrong on a
number of different levels and we can
talk about that but repeatedly there
have been errors made where it's like
you knew you could do better you knew
the
facts and yet you
still openly misled the public on what
was really going on I mean again so many
so many examples on vaccine safety on
pregnant women should be getting this
six months old should be should be
getting this it's safe and effective
when we neither know about safety nor
long-term
Effectiveness there wasn't even an
approach that many European countries
took of let's really focus on high-risk
groups and arguably you know give it to
to them where we see most amount of
benefit everyone else um you know here's
what we know here's what we don't know
you know the initial trials say that the
co vaccines reduce symptomatic infection
for the first few months we don't know
about longterm you know we didn't test
mortality so we we can't really tell
longterm on severe coid although there
was some data afterwards that seemed to
have suggested that but we don't know
about safety we're not really sure and
and and this actually goes now we can
kind of segue into some of the recent
news of like people recently who kind of
bought this mainstream information on
coid uncritically and understandably
fell victim to some of the stuff and now
have recently come out and said oh that
was a mistake there's a number of
examples a lot of people know about this
uh Megan Kelly recently saying she went
to her doctor and got tested positive
for for some kind of autoimmune issue
now she was vague about it so I don't
know what the details are but she asked
her doctor about could this be related
to the vaccine because there is
certainly a link between Co the MRNA
vaccines and certain autoimmune
conditions and the doctor said something
like yes it could definitely be possible
a lot of people with the vaccine have
been getting this now obviously we don't
know for sure it could be totally
unrelated but you know Megan said at the
time um in this recent interview that
she basically regrets getting the VAC at
the time um and not making a smarter
decision same thing with v ramaswami a
republican uh candidate for the
presidency um talking about how he got
the the first two shots and regrets
taking it in light of what we know about
the myocarditis risk which is
concentrated in younger males and he
happens to be I believe in his late
30s uh and then Elon Musk recently
saying that his third booster shot
almost landed him in the hospital
right and and I believe he's also talked
Elon about how I believe um some family
relative their son who I believe is an
adolescent male got myocarditis after
the vaccine tons and tons of these
stories and this relates to I'll just
say one last thing to a recent piece
that I did with Dr Anish Koka in
Philadelphia he runs a leading
Cardiology clinic and his Clinic
administered the MRNA vaccines in in big
numbers mostly to elderly uh people
mostly people over 60 65 but some people
under the age of 20 and 30 some younger
people involved and I I spoke to him and
he's been very honest on this topic he
himself is double vaxed and boosted as
well as his wife and one of his
daughters I believe is imuno compromised
so he was very worried about coid not at
all a conspiracy theorist very
reasonable smart guy Pro vaccine
generally he told me up front he said in
light of all this information that's
come out on the myocarditis front I
regret I seriously regret giving this
vaccine especially to younger people and
violating their informed consent when at
that
time we did not know about safety and
efficacy the way we know certain things
now right at that time I was wrong to
give this out knowing that these people
were at very low risk you know may not
have had comorbidities or were imuno
compromis and I gave it to them without
being AB absolutely certain about the
safety profile and that that to me is a
level of honesty whether it's Megan
Kelly Elon V but this in particular Dr
Nish Koka saying that he would have done
differently if he could you know change
his decision now that that is what you
call epistemic humility right I was
wrong at the time and now my views have
changed and now I'm going to look at the
world differently here is how my
narrative has changed here is how the
system in which I use to uh understand
reality and and analyze data has changed
and I'm a human I get things wrong we
all get things wrong so here's how I'm
going to act differently not this other
frankly of like oh at that time
I was actually right because that's what
the data said now things have changed
but I was right at the time and I was
right and I was appropriately worried
along every step of the way because
that's what the FDA and the CDC and Eric
toel were saying therefore I was right
at the time it's like no no ow up to at
that time you being wrong about some
very ious things and that's okay to be
wrong because we're humans and we get
things wrong all the time wrong and one
of the things that they were wrong about
was the reliability of the messaging
that was supposedly derived from the
data which we now know it was wrong
because we have better information
but you know uh the the Megan Kelly
situation
um is interesting for me you you
probably do not know but I remember
vividly that Megan Kelly had me on her
show and she took me to task for a tweet
that I had made and I had already
corrected it I had deleted it reposted
it and explained that I had made an
error in my tweet but that the theme of
the Tweet was still one that I believed
in my claim in the Tweet was that
virtually everybody that I had talked to
who had gotten the
vaccines had a story to tell about a
reaction and that a lot of this was
frightening it turned out there were a
few people that I had forgotten that I
had talked to so it wasn't quite as
Extreme as I had said but nonetheless I
did have an incredible number of
conversations with people who did not
volunteer that they had had a adverse uh
reaction until I asked them at which
point I found out so my point had been
yeah you have to ask in order to know
how common these adverse reactions are
and when you do you'll find out they're
very very common in any case Megan Kelly
gave me a hard time over this I thought
she was fair about it but uh it was a it
was a difficult interview and then
there's a question about well how much
of a coincidence is it that years down
the road she herself is now reporting a
severe adverse event and I I can't you
know obviously any individual case could
be a coincidence but the fact is I also
other people that I have Tangled with
over the safety of these vaccines also
have people in their immediate circle
who have had very serious Adverse Events
yes and so in any case the the real
point is the number of Adverse Events
here is truly staggering it is truly
staggering such that it uh if we look
around our Circle and evaluate honestly
it is touching all of
us yeah yeah there's a lot I have to say
about this because so so this leads to
and we should close the loop on how you
know I got into this on the coid front
um
so 2021 vaccine mandates start getting
pushed in my Province BC and federally
in Canada started seeing this in the US
as well um basically you know mandates
of you know I couldn't exercise at a gym
couldn't leave the country couldn't get
on an airplane or a train or weddings
large Gatherings number of different
places for not getting the vaccine and
me at the time
I completely going in with the blank
slate as much as possible Right on the
stuff and being like
okay what's the risk what's the benefit
and one of the first people I spoke to
was Dr J bararia which eventually led to
our collaboration on on substack now but
he was one of the first people I spoke
to because I in attempts to try to make
sense of what was going on just on the
raw data hearing about the risk of
myocarditis first being reported in
Israel and then by the US Military
I was very concerned about that
particular risk and how high it was and
who it's affecting and when I spoke to
Jay you know when I had all these
concerns he was able to validate them
and say yeah yeah these are these are
real concerns and unfortunately the CDC
and the FDA and health Canada and Biden
and the US Surgeon General are not
actually taking this seriously like like
there there is something here that needs
to be uh taken seriously but these
experts are not talking about it in an
honest way and and so that right away
was like oh okay okay that doesn't make
sense why why am I being mandated to
take a shot where there's a unknown SL
unclear
slash uh concerning risk of myocarditis
that's at that point was not really
defined not properly stratified but we
had some we we had some rough indication
of what was going on and then at that
point I just started kind of looking
around and just started hearing about
serious Adverse Events
of uh young boys uh a couple of young
males in my city as well as one
individual in particular who I later
interviewed on on the substack people
can go check it out on the illusion of
consensus a 38-year-old law enforcement
member um it's kind of a long story but
the short of it is he was mandated to
take the vaccine as someone working in a
federally regulated industry right law
enforcement the RCMP and got his first
shot had some chest complaints that
eventually went away got his second
fiser shot and had this excruciating
chest pain um a few days afterwards was
in Victoria at the time Victoria BC and
he thought that it you know might have
been a virus or something he ate and
then his girlfriend forced him to call
the ambulance the ambulance came his
heart rate was something crazy like 180
190 maybe 200 um really high number and
got you know sent to the hospital right
away and the cardiologist um right away
said this is from the vaccine and and
and that's from what he said is is kind
of a rare thing because other people
that he had heard about um this law
enforcement member happened he himself
happened to hear about a couple of other
cases where people had gotten
myocarditis um right after the vaccine a
few days or weeks and their cardiologist
refused to say that this was from the
vaccine yet in this particular hospital
it appears that this individual locked
out because the Victoria hospital has a
specialized Cardiology unit so they were
able to take care of him right away and
they had the relevant specific experts
to to look after it but fast forward to
six months to a year later he's still
ailing from this condition not fully
recovered hasn't gone back to his job um
for months couldn't exercise couldn't go
to a gym he was a very healthy guy and
that so hearing about stories like that
and then writing about it for me it was
like kind of a bit of an Awakening like
oh
people are being actually harmed by
these shots and why am I hearing about
it so much am I just an un you know an
unlucky person or just is this some
weird coincidence where I just happen to
hear of these I mean that's possible it
could be I wondered the same I wondered
the same thing am I am I the only one
and then I started looking around asking
other people and then this relates to
some other stuff too the I was also
hearing about the menstrual
irregularities right virtually all of
the sort of young uh women in my circles
from friends and family members and
relatives I would say the vast majority
of them that I knew about and I started
asking around awkwardly like hey is this
a thing or you know what's going on and
they're like oh yeah yeah this you know
this happened to me I had serious
vaginal bleeding and menstrual you know
irregularities I remember tweeting about
this like I'm hearing a lot about this
what's going on here and people left and
right were saying this is completely
unsupported there's no data this is
conspiracy theory and then I remember at
the time my friend Ricky Schlott who uh
has a book coming out with Greg Greg
lukanov she writes for the New York Post
she went she came to my defense on
Twitter and said hey guys stop piling on
RAV this actually happened to me and I'm
at the time 20 202 20 or 21 and saying
this happened to me and lots of my
female friends we experien severe
menstrual irregularities and public
health has not acknowledged us and we're
concerned about what what's going on
here and so the the totality of all of
these anecdotes for me was enough to
which for me was enough to take a
serious look at at the facts and the
data and to be very very suspicious and
skeptical of what public health was
saying right even as previously someone
who got all the vaccines someone as
recent as senior year of high school
which you know wasn't that long ago was
was 2019 you know the the school said
that oh we have the flu shot coming in
um the nurses are downstairs you can go
and get it and I just you know gave a
quick call to my mom hey the flu shots
available can I take it she's like yeah
I'll go for it I was like great didn't
think about it once went and got my
flute like I've I've always been very
Pro vaccine never been skeptical on any
of this stuff but suddenly this totality
of not not a totality but this initial
exposure to these deeply troubling
anecdotes pushed me in this direction of
investigating this
further yeah I mean I have a parallel
story um I was a very strong believer in
the utility of vaccines I was never a
believer that they were inherently safe
it's a Preposterous thing to imagine but
I was not nearly skeptical enough of the
safety
profile of vaccines until coid happened
and the lies here were just too blatant
to
ignore um and I would also point out
that all of the things you're describing
all of these young people who were given
these vaccines that was all predicated
on the idea that we were trying to reach
herd
immunity and that it was therefore
necessary to vaccinate everyone which is
why ostensibly they did not age stratify
the
recommendations but the problem is they
apparently knew that at best they'd had
no evidence that these things sto
transmission which of course they don't
and at worst they knew and pretended
that it stopped transmission hence the
claim that the virus stops with you Etc
which you mentioned earlier right so
they only had evidence for the first
couple of months that transmission
reduced significantly it uh certainly
was no basis to think you could control
this virus by getting uh full
penetration with these vaccines yes so
um the idea that in light of that the
unknowns were not sufficient for us to
keep these vaccines from being inflicted
on people who faced very little risk
from the disease itself is a um
monstrous oversight to say the least as
you pointed out earlier in our
discussion the people who suffer from
the vaccine injuries are different from
the people who suffer from the uh the
viral injuries and therefore um to the
extent that there was any argument at
all for these vaccines it could have
been limited to people who stood in
principle to gain something and it do
not need to be given to people who could
have faced uh Co gotten a much more
robust immunity uh from their infection
and not faced the risk of a serious
adverse event that would been the
obvious way to handle it and there's
something Unholy about what appears to
be a insatiable desire to inject the
maximum number of doses of especially
mRNA vaccines possible irrespective of
any medical or epidemiological
justification
yeah yeah I I I should go back to so the
the
journalistic uh Journey that I've been
on
so um started hearing about these cases
and I wanted to write about these in
many of the places I was writing for and
I've deliberately not named any editors
or any Publications where this is going
on don't want to get into any big Wars
with Legacy Media Outlets or anything or
or even alternative Outlets but I I
tried to publish on this front and long
story short I couldn't the message I
explicitly was given was that we are a
pro vaccine publication we're not going
to publish this our paper encourages
vaccinations we don't want to promote
vaccine hesitancy we don't think this is
conducive to the public discourse to the
the epidemiological research even though
a lot of these articles featured uh
people like Dr J bachara and benai Pasad
uh Martin korf other people and that I
mean that to me was just another um
shock was like okay so here's a problem
and I want to write about it but there's
another problem here that the
institutions don't want us to talk about
this honestly the institutions that
again I'm being vague here but
previously allowed dissent on the social
justice stuff and when we know some of
those institutions we know some of those
people personally um but these places
allowed descent on this stuff but not
here and there's been some recent things
that I've uncovered actually can go into
that briefly of actually I found out
recently that um I don't know if you
know about this Brett um um I'm curious
what your thoughts would be on this but
places like the New York Times the New
York Post uh Washington Post many other
mainstream Publications were actually
paid by the federal government to
promote the co
vaccines they were paid explicitly paid
you have here's an advertisement from
the CDC and the FDA why vaccines are
beneficial for kids and adults and
here's why you should get it so isn't
that a serious conflict of interest that
we should be talking about like can we
really rely on the Atlantic and the New
York Times for coverage on vaccine
injuries when those same places are
being paid by the government who are you
know have deals with fiser and madna and
all these complex uh networks between
the FDA and pharmaceutical companies to
promote these products
that's fascinating I mean several things
you've said are fascinating the idea
that that Publications were being paid
to advocate for vaccines which made it
impossible for them to do
journalism um the statement we are a
Prov vaccine
publication what could that possibly
mean I this goes back to my point about
whatever you think about vaccines and
you know until um 2021 I thought vaccin
uh were among the greatest medical
successes in
history um I now question that based on
uh a great deal more evidence than I had
at the time but there is no argument
that they are inherently safe because
there have been numerous examples where
vaccines have turned out to be very
dangerous and therefore the idea that a
publication would Express a
general uh stance on vaccines thereby
making it impossible for them to call
into question a bad vaccine or call into
question the process that leaves a bad
vaccine on the market that's a shocking
uh Declaration of Allegiance with no um
scientific justification
whatsoever so yeah what you're talking
about the the paying of Publications um
to embrace a particular vaccine
especially one about which almost
nothing is known because it's brand new
that
is I am I
am
groping for the example you know the
only thing I come up with is the Peola
Scandal but in the Peola Scandal it was
uh music that was artificially being
hyped the danger of which is much less
than you know a pseudo urine stabilized
lipid nanop partical cated mRNA and
coding a cytotoxic protein right that's
a recipe for disaster and to to pay
Publications to shill for it is a
shocking breach of the public trust to
say the very least yeah yeah so that
that response I was getting from
Publications was quite shocking and
quite disorienting
and led to my migration on substack
which I I had no interest in doing I I
know at some point Clyde wthin from
substack who's fantastic I think you're
in touch with them as well um he's he's
great he I think he reached out to me
and we were talking about getting me on
substack and I was like no hell no I I I
don't want substack because I like
having someone to you know to edit my
work and to fact check and to go through
this process and I like having someone
for accountability like I I generally
like collaboration and being in an
institution to be honest um you know
they say too much Freedom equals tyranny
like you want some sort of guidelines
and regulations and people to keep you
accountable but I was left with no
choice Brett I had to go to substack
because the message I was getting was
we're not going to publish this work um
but you know in some cases it was like
feel free to keep sending us stories
about cancel culture and identity
politics it's like it's just like what
like I mean th those are serious topics
and I'll talk about them anytime and I'm
happy to but this idea that I'm only
going to just endlessly write about
cancellations at universities and the
next social justice fad it's like this
is a really serious issue and I want to
write about it and it led to many many
months of frustration and lost income
and just I mean I I look back on that
and I have so much gratitude for where
I'm at right now with this pro project
with Jay and and and having the kind of
platform that's growing that I do right
now because there were many many months
where I was like I can't write at
these these places that I wanted to um
and now I have to go independent at a
very small audience but thankfully you
know some people have been you know kind
to me in promoting things you know
Jordan Joe Rogan and amplifying certain
things and so that's been kind of the
journey over the past uh year a couple
years has been going on substack and
writing about issues like vaccine
myocarditis side effects mandates where
again it's like you you know these
topics if you had told me Brett three
years ago or even two years ago or was
20121 in the summer when the mandates
were introduced so if you told me a bit
more than two years ago RAV you'll be
primarily writing about myartis a word I
probably didn't even hear about till
2021 to be honest um and vaccines it was
a pretty rare condition well well yeah
yeah and so I I had no interest in
vaccines I you know stayed away from
like I I took science courses in high
school but I I wasn't very good at them
to be honest physics I I failed grade 12
biology by the way which is not
something I should probably advertise
but I in grade 12 I took on like every
AP course and biology was the one that I
hated the most and I end up failing and
that that's a long story I should stop
advertising openly on the Dark Horse
podcast well I I will say you know you
are far from the first person who told
me they didn't think they had any
aptitude for biology and you know if you
dig deeply in those stories inevitably
it's about bad biology teaching which is
all too common yeah I mean I'll concede
I was just a bad student at the time and
I was I was interested in doing well on
AP Literature and uh Civics and math and
calculus but not anyway
um I so so so this this is a relevant
question I think when it comes to some
of the macro stuff is why do you have
people like me writing about this why do
I feel the need to write about vaccine
safety like a topic that I have no
expertise in no inherent interest in why
do I feel like I have to cover this
topic why is there a space for me to
write about this topic right someone
like me there is no utility or space for
someone like me to enter into the
discussion on
heart inflammation caused by the vaccine
if you had the New York Times and the
CDC and the FDA honestly talking about
this right I wouldn't be interested in
talking about this nor would there be
any need for me to talk about this no
one would be reading my work because you
already have the CDC and the New York
Times to trust but you've turned so many
people um
into you know thinkers on this topic
like PE people who never would have been
interested in this stuff I mean you know
why why is you know why is Joe Rogan
talking about this why am I talking
about this why I mean you're a biologist
so you're a little more relevant but but
even you you weren't talking about
vaccines to the extent you are right now
and the reason for that is is because
the public health messaging has been so
disastrously wrong on this front that
you you know we have this need for
substack we have the there's a real
space for podcasters to come in and to
present a narrative that's very
different from what the public health
what the public health um Dogma is and
it's it's it's honestly I mean put
putting aside whatever pat on the back I
want to give myself for being an honest
and you know whatever journalist on this
front and hopefully providing honest
coverage but it's it's honestly quite
tragic that I feel like my coverage on
vaccine injuries and vaccine mandates
has been better and More in line with
the signs than the CDC it's like why is
that why why why is a 22-year-old nobody
previously until a couple years ago
someone with no no phds or degrees in
epidemiology Immunology suddenly feels
like he himself and many people reading
me and many people taking me seriously
view viewing my work as more credible
than the CDC right that's not my fault
that's not the fault of Joe Rogan that's
the fault of the CDC and the FDA and
mainstream experts chosen by the New
York
Times Yes and if I can uh look at the
same picture from a slightly different
angle what you have is a system that is
not trying to figure out what is true
and certainly uninterested in sharing
the information with the public where it
knows that's the alarming Discovery is
that whether this
is Runaway Noble lies or whether this is
actually a an ulterior motive that has
taken over this system the reason that
you I won't describe you as a you know
20 something nobody the way you've
described yourself but the reason that
you as effectively an
amateur are able to beat the pants off
the CDC is because the CDC isn't trying
something has captured the CDC and the
CDC has a higher priority than figuring
out what's true and broadcasting it and
many of us have discovered this which is
why you have the odd fact of the high
quality
analysis is now outside the
institutions you have lots of doctors
who if you look at their Wikipedia page
these are Fringe quacks if you look at
their CV you discover they're anything
but Fringe quacks these are people who
are top of their field who have now
given up careers in many cases in order
to speak the truth on these topics where
are they speaking the truth on something
called called a podcast a totally
unregulated uh envirment with as you
know might be regulated in Canada well
yeah I guess that's another story for
another podcast but yeah I have to
update my model but yeah the idea that
substack and podcasts are where the high
quality analysis is going to be tells
you how deeply sick the system that is
supposed to be doing that analysis
actually is it's really um you know it's
in its depth throws and many of us are
out here trying to warn people the
system that's supposed to be protecting
you is actually steering you into danger
yeah yeah and and we should totally
concede this obvious point I don't know
why this is a point that has been made
by some people that we know that we need
institutions we need institutions that
we can rely on that we can trust um and
we can't only figure this out through
substacks and through this infinite
Division and you know all these
different branches on substack and
podcast where everyone has their hot
takes on vaccines and all these things
that that that that's a totally
dysfunctional model right to have this
much division this many infinite sources
of information everyone with their own
experts I don't think there's anyone
that disagrees anyone reasonable that I
know of that disagrees with this um
position that we need institutions and
that substack and podcasting is a
dysfunctional default to go to for
complex topics pertaining to our health
right won't call it dysfunctional
because it has been a lifesaver but what
I will say well well dysfunctional in
the long term if the institutions
continue to fail us and we have 20
different podcasts to listen to and we
can't ever trust the CDC and the FDA
anymore that to me is completely
dysfunctional right well it it is no
substitute for institutions yes that
work that said there are those um in our
various circles who say that the import
importance of Institutions is so great
that even if they are failing we must
listen to them and not listen to the
people who've shown a track record of
being right on substack and podcasts and
that's nonsense the fact is until the
institutions are rescued from whatever
has captured them we are stuck with the
system uh of podcasts and substacks
because it at least has some capacity to
actually uh resolve a coherent picture
so I don't like that at all I want look
I invested in science I want to live in
a world where we have scientific
institutions that are capable of
enlightening us and allowing us to steer
away from self harm based on Insight but
that's not the world I'm living in and I
know it yes and until then what I'm
going to have to do is I'm going to have
to go to the places where the exiled
adults are and I'm going to have to
listen and I'm going to have to do my
sorting which of these these people
really are the exiled adults trying to
tell me something and which of them are
fakers and that's not an easy job but um
the institutions so routinely fail now
we don't have a choice yes yeah and I'm
glad we're saying this openly and get
and getting this out of the way because
there seems to be some confusion on this
front as if we don't want institutions
or we think we can just do this by no no
no we every we want institutions aside
from some anarchists who don't want any
reliable authorities and just want you
know the public to decide everything we
as reasonable people want institutions
right but the institutions have failed
so much you have you know Publications
on substack you know some individual
writers earning millions of dollars and
doing so well and podcasts excelling to
the point of just absurdity because the
mainstream messaging on this front has
been so disastrously WR disastrously
wrong over and over again to the point
where it's like when can I go back to
trusting you know the CDC and the FD
they continue to fail us more and more
continuously with the new push for the
booster which we can talk about it's
like they're continuing to embarrass
themselves in a way where if you were
mildly critical of them before or were
critical in some ways like you know it's
like the C CDC and the FDA and the the
surgeon general's office and the Biden
Administration and the Trudeau
government and mainstream you know
pediatricians and you know many doctors
near you all you have this this this
kind of False Consensus in my view but
there is this consensus among our
scientific institutions right now that
you should get the new updated booster
shot right which has been tested in
madna in 50 people which by the way
there was one incident that required
medical attention one serious adverse
event and that 50 person trial so 150
for whatever that's worth and we don't
know what exactly happened there and
we're looking for like we hope they can
tell us what is that myocarditis or an
autoimmune issue or is that a heart
attack like what is that I don't know
and then the fiser arm you have test in
10 mice and that we Ram through
emergency use authorization which
deliberately allows you to cut corners
and to speed up the approval of a drug
or vaccine because of of a of a
perceived or purported
emergency this is the main story
messaging now get the new booster shot
it is safe and effective and we know
this to be the case and you have people
previously who were um in agreement with
the messaging people like Dr Paul offit
saying that I don't see the evidence
here you know maybe for people 65 and
over I'm not getting this even though I
believe Paul is like 72 so you know he's
not getting this himself um yet the CDC
and the and the FDA want you to get this
and so this is a big question for people
who um have been on the side of of
Defending these institutions and not um
being honest about what's really going
on is do you agree with the FDA and the
CDC right now and if the answer is yes
if you think that they are right in
pushing every American by the way not
not just like adults but I'm almost
certain it's six months and older but um
at the very least all you know children
of a certain age I'm pretty sure it's
six months and older actually they want
everyone boosted with the new coid shot
if you agree with that well I I feel
like we can't explain anything to you
anymore because because even people who
were previously in accord with those
institutions are now in disagreement
with them I mean you mean just there's
so many people that disagree with that
now but if you don't agree with them now
which I suspect some people are in that
boat well why not why not be in
agreement with them why not just default
to the CDC and the the FDA if you
trusted them previously you know you
know where's the line between where they
were wrong and where they were right
right and and and and there there has
been some people who have said well you
know I think they all right and I'm
going to be getting this shot like the
annual flu shot without at all
acknowledging that those are two very
different things the flu shot has been
tested for decades and decades and we
know the safety profile it's nothing of
the sort um that we have with these mRNA
vaccines so it's it's honestly just an
absurd um ridiculous claim to make that
those two things are somehow um similar
but this is where we are right now where
the FDA and the CDC continue to
zealously push for these pharmaceutical
products absent safety and efficacy
well I want to look at it from a
different
perspective if this had been an honest
effort to keep the public
safe then it would update with
information about the fact that the
vaccines did not turn out to be safe in
the way people had initially portrayed
them nor did they turn out to be
effective in the way people initially
portrayed them that would cause you if
this if it was originally an error then
the messaging would rapidly shift in the
direction of you know not children
should be getting their booster but
children should under no circumstance be
getting this booster and you know if we
if we were now pushing it only towards
people who were old and had multiple
comorbidities you could at least imagine
that this was an honest effort to update
with information the fact that the
messaging doesn't change at all says
wait a minute this is an advertisement
this is an advertisement for a product
that is now being broadcast through an
official Channel and I want to go back
to the issue um of
Institutions I take no responsibility
for doing this work outside of an
institution U framework because I have
been shouting about the problem of
capture for at least 20 years I've been
trying to call attention to the fact
that this capture was creeping and that
it was escaping the original
conceptualization of the capture of the
regulators and it was taking over
institution after institution we are now
finally at a place it's like if you had
been on the Titanic and you had been
talking about the defects in the boat's
design and the uh Insanity of speeding
through the North Atlantic when there
were obstacles and then it hits an
obstacle then the point is well I tried
to tell you I tried to tell you that
this was going to happen I'm not arguing
that lifeboats are a solution for the
North Atlantic in the winter they're not
but they're better than nothing and the
fact that we are left with lifeboats is
the fault of the people who designed the
ship didn't put enough lifeboats on it
and then allowed the captain to speed
through the North Atlantic to set a
record right so the point is yeah
podcast substack those are lifeboats
nobody is arguing that's the right way
to get across the Atlantic I don't know
why that's the position then like why
some people is there some weird straw
man thing going on that like maybe we
some people think that people in our
camp you know whatever Camp you and I
wherever you and I converge or diverge
whatever but the sort of alternative
side to co that we think that we can get
through this with substack and podcast
only and that we don't want institutions
like like we agree we need institutions
so I don't know what the point there is
being made to be honest right I mean my
point is if if if confus some of our
friends are talking about this as if we
are not interested in
institutions the fault is on them they
should have listened earlier when the
institutions might have been salvageable
and the fact is yeah they're gone those
institutions no longer function and you
can tell because they're not updating
their advice in light of evidence that
we now have it in fact
the irony of the whole situation is to
the extent that the institutions are now
grudgingly talking about things like
myocarditis Adverse Events age
stratification all of these things to
the extent that these things have
percolated into the public conversation
it's only because of the unregulated
space of substacks and podcasts that
that discussion ever broke otherwise we
would we would be told right now that uh
this had been a spectacular success and
it had demonstrated the power and safety
of the MRNA vaccine platform that's what
they would say and the fact is they
still do say it but they can't say it
with a straight face and lots of people
push back because we manag to get enough
experts in front of the public by not
going through the institutions that's
what we didn't yeah and it it's to me
it's a very weird biased focus of only
focusing on and and I'll I'll get in a
minute to the other side of the problem
which which does exist but there's this
weird lack of focus lack of coverage is
transparency about the continued
mistakes and dishonesty on the part of
CDC and FDA like CDC had
um um you know up until very
recently continuing to say that for this
new booster shot the the risk of vaccine
myocarditis is lower than the risk of
myocarditis from coid therefore all
young boys and girls and everyone should
be getting this you have Ashish ja the
coid White House coordinator saying that
if you get this new booster shot your
risk of hospitalization and long coid
will go down if you get this thing
complete scientific claims that
have no I mean they're unscientific that
have no basis in reality these people it
is not it is not exaggeration to say
that these people are propagandists on
that front okay they it doesn't mean
that they're totally wrong about
everything I'm sure some of these people
are nice and ethical in other ways and
have credentials that are solid you know
and whatever I I don't know I don't know
why you would say that ra they are lying
to the public in ways that will put
young people who should not be placed in
danger into danger I don't know why
you'd make excuses for them no no no I'm
not making excuses I'm saying they might
be right about other things potentially
but they are so wrong about this thing
that it's that we would agree it's
disqualifying to me just like saying
that this person uh who just plowed
their vehicle
into uh a crowd think of all the people
they didn't
hit yeah right my feeling is no this
person just recklessly operated their
vehicle in such a way they just killed a
bunch of people that's all I'm
interested in talking about actually the
fact that they might not have killed
other people or they might have a you
know a perfect pitch or whatever we
might say in their defense is irrelevant
yeah and there's an important point to
be made here of if you don't want to
listen to me or to you or to Joe or Jay
bararia or Martin korf or whoever listen
to the people in these organizations who
have been dissenting on this front Okay
you have winter of
2021 two top senior officials at the FDA
were part of the vaccine approval
process you can look this up um they had
a piece in uh the The Washington Post it
was uh believe the names are Dr Philip
Krauss and Mary and Goober if I'm
getting that right they openly said we
are leaving the FDA because we feel
politically pressured to approve the the
booster shot in young healthy people for
which there's no evidence for we feel we
are being pressured or coerced in some
way to push things that have no
scientific basis therefore we're leaving
the organization okay and there's many
other examples too you there's Great
Piece in Barry Weiss's substack um maybe
last year I think with Dr Tracy Beth hog
and and Dr Marty McCary who have various
contacts in the CDC and the FDA and
honestly this piece was quite incredible
and should be reread many times over and
should be taken so seriously because
they they had connections at the FDA and
the CDC and many people at these
institutions told and I I wrote this
down actually because it was so striking
to me I I I remember reading the piece
at the time and then I I just got the
quotes again for us today because it
reveals so much of what's going on top
CDC officials quoted in this article in
in Barry's substack at the FDA and the
CDC saying things like this is a horror
show for kids you can inject them with
this Co vaccine or squirt it in their
face it's just as
effective uh one uh uh official I didn't
write down here ex was it CDC or FDA one
of the two saying it seems criminal to
push these shots to push these shots
these M shots in kids one FDA official
saying if you speak honestly about this
you get treated
differently this is not this is not my
quote this is not my opinion this is
people within those
organizations who are trying to do good
who feel stifled who feel like the way
that their organization is being run is
completely corrupt and dangerous and not
actually in the you know solely serving
the interests of the people but
actually violating informed consent and
pushing products where they're actively
dangerous and lack the data on efficacy
this is this is these people so can we
trust the FDA and the CDC when people in
their own organizations irrespective of
what you and I think are saying on this
topic can we trust these
places yeah clearly not and for dozens
of different reasons um I would also
point out you know in light of your uh
your point regarding the was it a White
House spokesperson who was saying that
uh the vaccines reduce long coid and
hospitalization right the new this is an
increasingly obvious pattern where
people who are in a position that they
have to know better say things that will
not fool anyone who is informed but will
successfully fool people who are
ignorant and we saw this couple days ago
with the Nobel committee that
awarded the 2023 Nobel Prize for
physiology and medicine for the pseudo
urine uh alterations to the MRNA
transcripts in these very vaccines and
in their press conference in describing
this award they specifically say in
response to the question from a Chinese
journalist who asks we don't know
anything anything about the long-term
impacts of these vaccines are we worried
about this they assure her that there's
nothing to be worried about in part
because the
mrnas uh are so transient in their
existence in the
body that's absurd in light of the fact
that they just gave a Nobel prize for
the pseudo urine enrichment that causes
these things to become durable so
they're representing this as something
that is gone within days to a week when
we actually know that these things
persist in the body for months so the
Nobel committee has
awarded uh has awarded a Nobel prize for
the stabilization of mrnas that makes
them longlasting and in the press
conference they Tout The ephemeral
nature of these uh mrnas as reason to be
confident that there are no long-term
effects it's a Preposterous statement
what are you to do with the fact that
the committee that just gave the award
is now saying something in direct
contradiction to the very mechanism for
which they just called the world's
attention it it's Preposterous the only
person that could fool is somebody who
doesn't know what's going on yeah yeah
yeah on the question of long-term safety
there's been some interesting recent
data and I I feel like I I skipped over
a couple things I should I should have
said earlier um I'll just maybe quickly
go into that uh with respect to you what
I've been writing about and how I came
to form my perspective on this um so
I'll quickly just back up here quickly
and just say that um when I started
going independent and started hearing
about these stories of vaccine
myocarditis I then delved into the data
and found a
serious uh risk for myocarditis up to
one and 200000 um young men in
particular concentrated in madna dose 2
um
but and there there's a lot of data
points I can go into there but that
alone doesn't tell the full story
because there's so much else going on so
many other data points that show that
this is a far bigger risk than we
thought it was even among the people who
have acknowledged that oh okay madna do
to don't give it to young boys give it
to everyone it's like there there's a
lot more going on here and what I
started doing was tracking some of the
international data countries that keep a
closed database on this and I found that
in 2021 you had countries like Israel
France uh Germany and a select few us
hospitals for which I could find data
had striking increases in myocard
myocarditis rates in 2021 but not
2020 increases of up to 30%
75% there was one peer-reviewed study in
particular by Dr Revy who a MIT
researcher uh this was in nature which
found um in Israel where they keep a
close database of 911 calls he basically
put together 911 calls for acute cardiac
events versus the distribution of mRNA
vaccines and finds a direct not not a
causation because you couldn't prove
that there but a direct correlation
between distribution of mRNA vaccines
goes up Suddenly big spike in 911 calls
for acute cardiac events specifically in
16 to 39 year olds in both men and women
I believe actually the study strangely
enough showed a bit of a higher rate
among women by some slight margin
which that as well poses some strange
questions there but you had data like
that where it was
unequivocal um increasingly so with with
more and more other studies um as well
where you you have the reported cases of
myocarditis right cases that fall under
the clinical diagnosis but then you also
had studies and weirdly enough not in
the US but in other countries studies
that looked at subclinical myocarditis
so patients that weren't necessarily
presenting um symptoms and weren't
admitted to the hospital but these were
patients who were surveyed for a marker
of myocarditis without having sought
treatment so these are people who had it
when they looked into them but there was
no reason to think they had it at the
point that their blood was looking
right so there's one tie study in
particular and it was very very small so
you know you can make it that way you
will but it was couple hundred uh young
kids 13 to 18 after the second fiser
dose about 3% of those uh young kids had
evidence of myocardial injury 1% was
clinical myocarditis but 2 to 3% overall
of subclinical plus clinical a lot of
those cases were subclinical as in
elevated troponin levels which show
evidence of some um myocardial um damage
that um is you know as a study author
said likely short term easily resolvable
um at worst a few months and from my
interviews with people if you get
clinical myocarditis it takes several
months of no exercise no um uh you know
elevating your heart rate is a
potentially dangerous thing so doctors
recommend you to stay away from even
like walking fast upstairs and they're
given a bunch of medications long-term
effects not known but there was one
recent study from Hong Kong that came
out this summer and I delved into it
with my friend Dr Nish Koka at uh Koka
Cardiology in Philadelphia and we went
into it and the study showed over 50% of
people who in this study sample um
primarily young people who had gotten
vaccine myocarditis over 50% of them at
the one-year followup had evidence of
scarring in their heart muscle over 50%
and this Jes with other CDC data as well
where you look at the long-term six
months eight months one year followup
and you have a significant percentage of
people that have not
recovered that is so alarming and I mean
it just the fact that these things were
pushed without knowledge of these things
and eventually when we did find more
more evidence that these things were
that these vaccines were dangerous
particularly to young people the fact
that they were continually pushed
without informed consent to me is is
just completely outrageous and perhaps
even criminal when we look at yeah it's
beyond criminal so the fact that they
continue to be pushed in a non-age
stratified way is the indication that
whatever is driving this policy does not
care about killing young people because
you could with no
harm irrespective of how good these
vaccines are you could with no harm
exclude young people from the risk that
they apparently face
disproportionately by excluding them
from this campaign and healthy young
people do not die of coid so the fact is
you the obvious thing to do from from
the perspective of Public Health is to
recommend against and actually to forbid
did healthy young people from getting
these vaccines and if you feel that they
are necessary for older people which I
do not but if they have a disagreement
about that they could advise them for
older people the fact that they don't do
that means that they are willing to have
young people die needlessly people who
get no benefit from these shots and you
know let's put it this way I don't know
if it's technically criminal what
they're doing but it is beyond criminal
and in fact that's the point about the
nberg code the violation of informed
consent is above the question of the law
this is a set of questions a set of
moral questions over which the West
literally hung seven
doctors for violating informed consent
before it was even codified the idea
being that for a doctor it was so
obvious that a patient had the right to
informed consent that to violate that
right was a hanging offense and somehow
at this point it's it's a nothing Burger
we just violate people's informed
consent we give them vaccines we know a
lot about the hazards of and don't tell
them we don't tell them about the
contents we don't tell them about the
impurities we don't tell them about any
of the things that they would need to
know to make a reasonable Choice it's
insane yeah and and we should bring in
one other data point here is the the
fact that this isn't just myocarditis
either and there's this weird straw man
well some people say well okay myotis
young boys don't give it to them
everyone else get it but no it's it's
not just that and the best study we have
on the overall adverse event rate comes
from Dr Joseph Raymond um who led the
study was published in the journal
vaccine arguably the foremost reputable
uh Institution for um looking at these
things and him and on his team were
people like Dr uh sander Greenland one
of the most renowned bio staticians in
the US he's at UCLA Dr John K from
Stanford and and many other um
distinguished people in their field
Peter Doshi Dr I was going to mention Dr
Peter DOI who's an expert in um
Pharmaceuticals and they they just went
back from the original trials and just
counted serious Adverse Events and um
and and they were blinded in a way that
was quite compelling where we had
framing on our podcast recently uh Dr J
interviewed him and he was telling how
he was blinded so he didn't know which
adverse event was from the placebo or
the vaccine arm and him and his review
board looked at every single serious
adverse event and counted them and found
that in the fiser are in the fiser study
the serious adverse event rate was about
one in
550 combined with the madna when you add
those two together you have an average
serious adverse event rate of one in 800
so that includes myocarditis it includes
menstrual irregularities it includes
autoimmune issues blood clotting serious
serious Adverse Events is what they were
looking at these are not minor things
these are yeah these are serious Adverse
Events and the conclusion of their study
was that the overall rate of Adverse
Events exceeds the purported reduction
in hospitalization from coid vaccines
and they very clearly said it's possible
that these vaccines on a cost benefit
analysis could be favorable in people
over the age of 65 but you go lower down
the age gradient 50 40 30 especially
among healthy people is very like
perhaps almost certain that the cost
benefit analysis looking back on this
has been negative for vaccinating young
and healthy people with the MRNA shots
yes I think in it is increasingly clear
that the MRNA shots are net negative at
least the way they've been deployed and
probably under any circumstances but
about that study I want to make it very
clear for people who are listening that
study found an overall 1 in 800 rate of
serious ad ver events but it only
covered the very short period of the
trial itself in the case of fizer that
was literally one month so these are
Adverse Events that happen within one
month of getting the shot this says
nothing about what the actual rate of
Adverse Events is because we now know
that Adverse Events actually extend way
into the future for these things and
this is also for uh a limited number of
inoculations we don't know what happens
when you you've gotten you know two
shots and two boosters or whatever it is
so this is the low estimate for how
common these serious Adverse Events are
because it was over a very limited
window of time and without four boosters
or four shots so um you have to
extrapolate what is the actual rate of
Adverse Events if we weren't just
looking at the trial data but we were
looking at the people who had gotten
those initial shots and then had
continued on and the fact is there's a
there's a reason that we don't know
which is that Pharma plays a little game
which is as soon as it has demonstrated
what it regards as high
efficacy it is deemed unethical not to
vaccinate everybody in the study
including people in the control group so
what happens is they eliminate our
ability to see what the actual adverse
event rate is because everybody is now
in the vaccine group rather than the
placebo group right that's a trick they
play so that we cannot see the the
actual rate and even with that trick
we've got a 1 in 800 rate of Adverse
Events or serious Adverse Events right
yeah yeah and to go to your point about
it doesn't capture everything the that
subclinical rate that we found in that
one tie study which by the way was
replicated in a couple of other small
studies too and again they're small so
we don't really know but subclinical
myocarditis we really don't know what
the rate of that is like how many young
people's hearts have been damaged to
some degree whether that's transient or
longterm we don't know what is that
actual percentage we really don't know
and the studies that were supposed to be
done on this by the way that are
apparently complete there's some
interesting uh sort of behind the-scenes
stuff about this that we really don't
know but my friend uh Jessica Adams on
Twitter she's for some reason been just
amazing at at just pursuing this
constantly um the fiser madna were
mandated to complete subclinical
myocarditis studies particularly in
young males and that was due I believe
in December of last year and they got an
extension to like June and we still
don't have the results for that and I'm
getting very very suspicious not being
conspiratorial but I'm getting very
suspicious about why aren't those
results being released now it could be
it takes time or whatever but how many
billions of dollars have they generated
how many studies could they have done
this new booster shot they they could
have done a proper randomized controlled
study and enlisting large numbers of
people they have the money for that they
have the resources for that they could
have gotten the subclinical study done
way earlier than it's being done and I
and I wonder is it did they want to push
this new booster first and you know tell
people to get it before they release the
subclinical but that that study was due
many many months ago and we still don't
know the results for that and and one
other thing I'll say about that study
Brett is many people don't know that
vaccines have been pulled off the market
for adverse event rates far far far
lower than this one right Roda virus
vaccine was pulled off the market for an
adverse event rate serious adverse Event
Event rate for one in 10,000 swine flu
vaccine I Believe In 1976 was pulled off
for one in 100,000 adverse event rate
these vaccines there's best available
evidence if there's better evidence
someone can show me but the best
available evidence in in in this
particular this particular study shows
one in 800 and this this lines up with
one in 800 in the short period of time
during the trial we don't know about
subclinical myocarditis we don't know I
mean there recent studies on breast milk
there's a study in the Lancet that that
confirmed a previous study from last
year showing that traces of mRNA were
found in breast milk for a certain
amount of time after the vaccines uh
even though we even though the CDC and
the FDA said this was unequivocally safe
and effective for pregnant and
breastfeeding women not only that they
could take it but that they should take
it in light of this evidence and there's
recent studies also about the vaginal
bleeding risk which again we talked
about before that conf more and more
just confirming these risks that I've
been talking about for a couple years
things that initially would brand you a
conspiracy
theorist there there's an important
Point here we should make and I'd like
to hear your thoughts on this as well is
that the push back that we're going to
get about talking about this is oh this
is just the evolution of of the science
right this is things that we're learning
about and we can were true if that were
true the messaging would change and they
for example in in advance of them
releasing their subclinical myocarditis
study they might advise that young
people hold off until those results are
out and the fact that they are allowing
young people and in fact pushing young
people to get these vaccines before that
evidence emerges says that that they are
not interested this is not evolving
science in fact what they're doing is
resisting whatever might be in that data
you know people have not updated their
model sufficiently certainly the CDC and
the FDA hasn't but there are people
saying well things have changed now but
I wasn't was n wrong at the time I I'll
specifically say this is one of Sam
Harris's claims is well I wasn't wrong
at the time in July and August of 2021
to openly use my podcast as a platform
to explicitly advocate for not only why
maybe you could get the vaccine or why
it might make sense for some people but
why the case for getting vaccinated is
absolutely clear-cut that was a message
that I got from the making sense podcast
in July and August of 2021
and that message was sculpted and
sourced from someone like Eric toppel
and Nicholas cistus who were the the the
chosen experts on that podcast
anointed yeah and it's it's not just a
matter of the Sciences evolved on this
and now things have changed at that
time you were wrong to say the cas are
getting vaccinated is absolutely
clear-cut at that time we were not sure
about safety we had some evidence of
blocking transmission for some period of
time we knew people over 65 were at
higher risk and we should potentially
concentrate on them and arguably give
them the vaccine um I believe that was
actually your position Brett I I believe
it might have been substack piece on
Heather's PO on on Heather's substack or
you guys talked about it but I believe
that was the initial perspective on your
and Heather's part that this this seems
to make sense or could make sense for
over 65 but this idea that everyone
should be getting this thing
at that time was wrong especially when
many other experts disagreed on that
point right I spoke to Jay bachara you
know in that that exact time and Martin
korf and many other people Marty McCary
they were saying something very
different than Eric toppa was they were
saying actually we don't really know and
and and that's I mean in terms of safety
and long-term efficacy we're not really
sure we know who's at risk and based on
that we can make a rough calculation of
who should be encouraged to get this
thing while telling them that we're not
really clear about the exact risks but
there was that epistemic humility of
here's what we know here's what we don't
know epistemic humility does not say the
case are getting this experimental
inoculation is clear-cut epistemic
humility is saying here are the benefits
or here are the seeming benefits here
are some of the risks here are the
unknowns you here's my decision if you
want to say that but you should decide
um for yourself and make an informed
decision and we shall wait to see what
the emerging evidence shows at that
point the many people made that mistake
of being advocates for these shots and
they frankly have failed to update their
model accordingly with the the highest
quality evidence on the risks associated
with the MRNA
vaccines well it's uh it's worse than
that I do not remember Sam's particular
formulation but the argument that
the uh evidence available at that time
made it
clearcut means that there was not enough
room left in the unknowns for that
conclusion to change so the fact that
the conclusion has now changed means
that what was said back then was far too
certain and a failure to acknowledge
that is part of a broad pattern I'm
afraid to say on Sam's part of being
unwilling to look at his own record and
extrapolate from his failures and I
don't I don't want to focus terribly
much on Sam I know he's released some
recent stuff which I honestly have not
seen but um I do know that you've been
in contact with him and you might have
some things that you want to say yeah
yeah well well it's a private
communication and it's it's interesting
watching I saw Sam on Lex's podcast and
I mean in in general Sam has been very
openly critical about you and Joe not
pulling back any punches but he he
similarly I mean he was talking to Lex
about how he reached out to Elon for
spreading misinformation on coid and he
he reached out to him and it failed and
I feel a similar way but of a different
Viewpoint of of me trying to reach out
to
him credit to him for taking me very
seriously and engaging with me over a
very extended um chain of emails and
going back and forth over data I I
really credit him for that uh and
generally I'm a big a big supporter of
his and I of of particularly his waking
up app which I think is a phenomenal
resource for mindfulness and for
understanding some of our core um
spiritual questions about the illusion
of self and of ego and of our obsession
with our own thoughts Etc and so I he's
been a hero of mine for so so long and
there might be a book in the back which
he authored which which I think uh was
and is incredible but on this front I've
just been again without getting into the
private Communications because that's
ethically I feel like that's not right
and and by the way I I've also been
hesitant to really openly talk about him
over and over again because I I at some
point I feel like a public conversation
with him might be the right way to go on
some platform and I I want to be careful
in what I say but in in summation I've
just been very very disappo pointed in
the way he's handled this given his
previous messaging has been all we have
is conversation ultimately civilization
depends on our ability to have a
reasoned conversation on very important
topics and and he said he said the
alternative that we have is violence
that's that's literally the way he has
laid out the case and he has also said
that um when one says something and it
turns out to be incorrect the right
thing to do is to fix it as quickly as
possible that that is by far the best
course of action and so his continually
doubling down on wrong formulations in
this case and his refusal to discuss
this in particular with me is very
strange in light of beliefs that he has
been perfectly clear about yeah and and
this whole line of well I'm not an
expert so I'm not the right person to
talk to Brett's not the person right
talk to it's just this weird disconnect
there of on the one hand the case for
getting vaccinated is absolutely
clearcut and here's why you should get
it and here's why I got it and everyone
you know I think should get it minus you
know young boys that's one concession he
made saying that with such certainty and
very little humility but then also
saying I'm not the expert don't listen
to me I'm not the guy neither is Joe
neither's Brett you know neither's
whoever it's like either you talk about
this issue which he did and took a
position right his position was not I
don't know people should you know here's
what I'm doing I'm getting the vaccine
and my kids are and you can decide for
yourself his thing was advocating other
people do this and but then at the same
time saying I'm not the expert it's like
you can have it one way right either you
have a perspective in which case you
should def defend it and talk to people
who are critical of it and he's been
doing some recent interviews that I
think were um I mean he he spoke to
Majid at some point earlier this year I
listen to and I I thought I love Majid
and I you know I still like Sam but I
thought it was kind of a failure because
it was way too sprawling and way too all
over the place and focusing on a lot of
macro issues without kind of drilling
down on some very fundamental points
about what was you know what mistakes
were made but this this overall shift
that I I I that that he's taken where
it's like previously the kind of bravery
and courage and conversational skill and
aptitude that I saw with Sam was getting
in the ring with Christian
fundamentalists you know advocates for
Islam and debating them people on the
BLM side there was one debate I remember
actually with this one um comedian with
I think Joe was there and openly talking
about police shootings and racial
profiling Etc openly going into that
dangerous territory and holding his
ground right or wrong like there was
Infamous debate with shank yuger about
Islam which fantastic debate and
actually defending position to now well
we can't really you know unlimited
conversation is not the right way and
this is not something that I'm going to
get into I'm not the expert but also you
should get the vaccine and you should
get boosted it's like what that doesn't
make sense well since you raised the
issue of his talking to Mid I would also
point out he's talked to Russell Brand
yeah um I also thought by the way that
that was I like the conversation but I
thought it was a failure again just
overall it was just too sprawling not
enough time I feel like in two all over
the place like there needs to be a sit
down conversation and at some point I'd
love to talk to Sam about this and be
like okay 2021 this was your position
here's where I think you got it wrong
like go Point by Point as opposed to
these big macro discussions where all
the specifics get lost in my perspective
well I I hope he takes you up on that
but the fact that he's willing to talk
to Russell Brand yeah and Majid noaz but
not me and also he's expressed he's
willing to talk to Joe he's openly said
that several times he's happy to go on
Joe's podcast yep um the fact that he
would talk to these people whose
position was not in any way less extreme
than mine I don't think mine was extreme
but the fact that there uh is not a
tremendous amount of difference in the
hazard uh that I view these vaccines uh
as being versus what Majed believes for
example and yet he's willing to talk to
majet and not me suggests that there is
something about about a conversation
with frankly somebody who knows a lot
more about this topic than he does uh
that he is shying away from and frankly
at this point I have bent so far over
backwards to provide mechanisms that
would allow him to engage in this
without me pulling a gotcha on him um
that I think at this point it is fair to
read his um uh unwillingness to talk to
me on this topic as a forfeit on his
count on in his case he is forfeiting by
refusing to discuss it and he no longer
has uh any excuse based on uh
platforming or whatever because his
conversation with Majid and Russell
Brand uh and his willingness to talk to
Joe all suggest that this is um somehow
about uh about me and not about the
topic yeah and I feel like you should
you've already said this before let's
just do do it again in case he's
listening like you're happy to talk to
him with you bring your expert he brings
his expert and you can decide beforehand
which studies to talk about and which
topics to focus on you're willing you're
willing to go on you know whatever Joe's
podcast or you know I'm happy to
moderate a discussion you're happy to
bring whatever expert you want and
you're letting to him you're letting him
bring whatever person he wants to bring
to the table like you're willing to do
basically anything to talk to him well
that has been my position there's point
at which I show up to the field of play
and he doesn't show up and my feeling is
okay then you take the L then you're
telling us that you're not capable of uh
of prevailing in such a discussion and
that's why you're not showing up so what
we you know I'd rather we do this with a
discussion but no at this point uh Sam
has
lost his recent podcast the postmortem
on coid I I listen to it and again I'm
listening to it and I just feel like
it's there's some serious fallacies and
a misunderstanding of what's going on
just there's a couple things in
particular that really struck my
attention one in particular was this
complete misunderstanding of we alluded
to this before of who's at risk of coid
versus who's at risk of vaccine injuries
and his point
was we administered the co shots and if
we if we believe there's the the benefit
for mortality especially in older people
the amount of lives that vaccines have
saved even if 20 people 200 people 2,000
I believe he went up to
20,000 people died from the vaccines
he's like there's nothing to talk about
it's no big deal because on a cost
benefit analysis it makes sense just
like you know for example driving cars
on highways right we there's a number of
a staggering of number of
fatalities complete tragedies that we
accept because we want to get to places
on time we accept that as a society that
some number of people are going to get
killed on highways every year because of
efficiency and because of the way our
society runs and that's obviously Sam
involved in sophistry because as we have
made the point here multiple times on
this
podcast if there were a small number of
Adverse Events you could reduce that
number a great deal by age stratifying
the application of these vaccines and if
he has not been an advocate for age
stratifying these things
then he is effectively saying that a
small number of deaths that are
completely needless are okay with him
and they're not okay with me yeah let me
make this very clear for him if you know
2,000 people 20,000 people whatever
number of people died from vaccines that
group is concentrated among younger
healthier people that have higher risk
particularly of myocarditis and sudden
cardiac death and heart attacks and we
we think that number is very very low on
on net but that number exists and there
was a recent study from South Korea
where they um very comprehensively
looked at um myio carditis cases and
deaths associated with vaccine um
related to um sudden cardiac death and
they confirmed several cases of such of
concentrated among younger healthier
people particularly men between the ages
of 15 and 30 but also older where they
died right after the vaccine and there
was evidence of myocard injury and we
know this to be the case that there are
some number of people that have died or
had heart attacks severe cardiac
outcomes from this vaccine and we know
that group is very different from the
group that's been vulnerable um that
that that has been at risk for coid so
this idea that that's a risk that we
should bear it's like no no no that that
could have been easily mitigated if we
our policy had been over 65 you should
you should get it talk to your doctor
look at at the risk and benefits healthy
young people under the age of 50 or 60
with no comorbidities there's not clear
evidence of benefit and that could have
prevented whatever number 2,000 20,000
but this idea that that is a cost that
is Justified to bear is a complete
misunderstanding of who's actually at
risk of dying from the vaccine or
getting serious Adverse Events and who's
actually at risk of dying from coid
because those are very very different
risks and we could done a far far better
job at stratifying by age and by risk um
on this front well what's more his
argument is just simply childish
because he is treating this number of uh
supposed uh acceptable losses as if that
number is not climbing and the fact is
the evidence strongly supports the idea
that these vaccines are invading tissues
all around the body most critically the
heart but all around the body and that
when they do they are resulting in
damage to those tissues which is going
to reduce life expectancy so the problem
is we don't know the
full uh extent of years of life lost
degree to which the Aging of people has
been accelerated by the Damage Done by
these vaccines we will not know that
until this cohort has moved through life
and we will only know it if we measure
it so to treat this as if we know the
number and it's small and therefore
totally acceptable well it may be
acceptable to use Sam but that's the
result of a moral defect on your part it
is not the result of a careful
calculation of anything I'm just I'm BR
I'm just so confused on the this
fundamental thing he said again very
clearly on his last podcast Sam said
that if you you know didn't get the you
know if someone who didn't get the
vaccine um before get before being
naturally infected I don't understand
you at all he said I I I just don't get
why you would make that decision and if
you got natural immunity then okay that
that counts for something but before
being naturally infected I don't
understand why someone wouldn't get the
vaccine that that's a statement and I'm
like well does that include me does that
include my mom like my parents chose not
to get vaccinated um for different
reasons like like who's he talking about
there and why do you not like we've been
over this many times I feel like like
it's like we know who is at risk right
the the average person who died from
coid had four comorbidities their mean
age was something like 75 or 85 was very
high we knew who was getting this
there's been multiple multiple studies
that we can talk about from Italy and
Sweden showing that you know 98% of
people dying from coid had three plus
comorbidities Etc like like we we know
the data so and we knew this data at the
time this isn't just new information so
it was perfectly rational in July or
August and September of 2021 to say I'm
45 years old I'm healthy I don't have
any comorbidities I'm choosing not to
get vaccinated or for my kids to get
vaccinated that's a rational that was a
rational position that was not
irrational or crazy yet for Sam that was
completely irrational I I don't
understand why he would say that at all
to be honest Not only was it rational
but I literally do not know a single
person who made such a decision
who regrets it I know lots of people who
made the decision to get at least one
shot and regret it but I literally do
not know a single example of somebody
who resisted the shot as terrifying as
it was to do that in the face of the
kind of pressure that was exerted but
those of us who did not get the shot do
not regret it because frankly our
intuition that this shot was more
dangerous than we were being told has
been borne out in Spades right and we
should acknowledge the other side too
which is I think is important so you had
stories real stories of there was a lot
of like Christian pastors a number of
sort of elderly people activists who are
very antivaccine who on their deathbed
said they made a mistake and later died
people over 60 and and those examples
have been used by Sam and others to say
well okay clear problem misinformation
with deadly consequences first of all
again it's the problem of ification
those were not 25-year-old guys they
were not 47y old healthy women those
were people over the age of 65 with
multiple comorbidities which arguably
initially they should have been
encouraged and and perhaps should have
gotten the vaccine early on and well but
those people are also Downstream of a
systematic campaign to represent these
shots as much more efficacious than they
actually are and I don't know how deeply
you have delved into Martin Neil and
Norman Fenton's work on what they call
the Cheap Trick but
the impression that these shots were
highly effective was largely the result
of what has to have been a deliberately
constructed uh statistical artifact
where if you shove people into the
category of unvaccinated so long as they
come down with coid less than two weeks
from their
inoculation you create something in
excess of 80% apparent efficacy even if
you were injecting them with saline you
would get something like 83 plus%
efficacy it's completely not about the
contents of those shots so yes you may
have people on their deathbed saying
that they wish they had gotten
vaccinated but that's Downstream of a
campaign to portray these vaccines as
much more effective than they actually
were so you know right and then there's
a healthy vaccine user uh issue which
which I I bet many of these people
saying these things have no idea about
theams of of data on this how
unvaccinated people tend to be more
obese more unhealthy higher rates of
smoking more rural areas lower access to
or um uh uh less proper Access to Health
Care Etc so when you compare you know
unvaccinated people died 10x the rate of
vaccinated people that those cohorts are
very very different you can map that on
to Republican and Democrat as well well
Republicans after vaccines died at high
it's like there there's a lot of
complexity there that you when you're
comparing those groups you're getting a
very misleading um statistic because
you're not controlling for the relevant
variables I mean it fails like a grade
12 statistics comparison to be honest
yeah yeah no these things it's just like
the issue with the the Immunology that
underlies the hazard of these vaccines
you can fool people who don't know but
you can't fool somebody who deeply
understands statistics or or
immunobiology in that case it's clear so
what's being said is not designed to
fool those people it's designed those
people can spot it it doesn't matter it
has to fool the public that's the
purpose and it's very frightening to
live in an era where uh transparent
falsehoods that just aren't obvious to
non-experts are being circulated as if
uh they were valid science right we
should really get into this macro
problem which we've talked bit about
before too is again our Focus my focus
has been I think correct focusing on the
CDC the FDA madna and fizer and the
Trudeau government and the Biden men How
Deeply corrupted they've been and how
they've been completely dishonest on
advertising and propagandizing the
efficacy and safety of these vaccines I
I think if we're being
honest focusing primarily on that
problem as being the impetus for this
misinformation problem is accurate and I
think other people's Focus solely on you
know misinformation even if I want to
talk about actual misinformation which
does exist on the other side but
focusing on RFK and Joe Rogan and you
and me and other people even if we're
wrong it's like the the the predominant
problem is this is these institutions
that have been captured right you don't
rora would never be a vaccine skeptic
never was a vac vaccine skeptic before
2021 on on coid Okay the reason why I am
skeptical of this as someone who's so
anti-conspiracy theory is because the
FDA and the CDC have completely abjectly
failed so the problem isn't Joe Rogan
even if you want to say Joe Rogan's
wrong for argument sake or RFK is wrong
or you're wrong I'm wrong whatever it's
this is the problem okay but it just so
happens that at least on my front and
people like Joe you know Joe very early
on in like April of 2021 said hey if
you're healthy and and and you know
you're a 21-year-old I don't think you
should be getting this thing mainstream
media completely assailed him and
attacked him for being wrong when he was
absolutely right on that question right
he was ABS absolutely right his
intuitions were excellent now so it's
rational I think to predominantly focus
on these institutions as the impetus for
misinformation right absent the CDC and
the FDA failing I would not be writing
substack newsletters going into long
form analysis on the cardiovascular
impact of like it's like like that seems
so just insane to me for me to for me to
be writing about this out of all people
right no it's put us all in a position
that we did not expect to be in I want
to be an advocate for an excellent
vaccine to control a disease that I
really think is frankly more dangerous
uh than lots of people give it credit
for it's much less deadly but uh coid I
think is a serious disease I would have
loved an excellent vaccine and I
expected AB at the beginning I expected
that that's what was being delivered and
I have been alarmed into a position of
having to challenge it uh publicly which
has not been uh fun but we were left
with no choice before we get into the
solutions would I think is a good way to
to wrap this up there is the other
problem of misinformation and there is
and we should talk about it while having
the caveat of I think 80 to 90% of the
problem has been the institutional
failure and that should be focused on
but that doesn't mean that the other
side is right about everything right and
I've seen things where I've been like
this is complete people this
tendency on the other side of blaming
everything on the vaccine oh dementia
Alzheimer's all turboc cancers like
everything is like we see cases oh
that's that's from the vaccine right and
there's been so many things that have
been circulated there's one one piece in
particular this this blog post this
informal aggregation of of sudden I
believe cardiac deaths and heart attacks
that Dr Peter Mulla Amplified who I you
know had respect for and I think has
done some great work on this front but
he signal boosted this analysis that
showed particularly athletes a big surge
in s cardiac deaths and heart attacks
and but the analysis included like
suicides and people that clearly did not
die from the vaccine I don't know who
even authored it it was on some weird
website that I'd never heard of and he
signal boosted that and used that as a
basis to say that we have CLE data that
athletes are dying from the vaccine at
at a higher rate which could very well
be true but that piece of evidence was
complete horseshit and I believe he went
on Laura Ingram's show um or might have
been some other anchor I think it was
Laura's show and used that as his his
basis for arguing that point and so I
look at that and I'm like there is a
problem here that we have to be honest
not everything is from the vaccine
myocarditis existed before like there
were issues going on before the vaccine
yes we should be honest about the risks
but that does not mean we should we
should compromise in our honesty and the
sources that we're using and demonize
everything vaccine related no of course
people I mean look a certain number of
people young people spontaneously die
that happened long before coid um the
tendency you know if uh why am I
forgetting his name um comedian on
Threes
Company thre Threes Company he died of
an aortic dissection uh I'm embarrassed
I can't think of his name but anyway he
died long before coid but if it had
happened in the aftermath of Co
everybody would be blaming the vaccine
so this is obviously a problem where
you've got a pattern we do appear to
have a pattern of uh serious Adverse
Events uh right up through death and it
is hard to disentangle that pattern
especially in light of a system that is
hellbent on not investigating we've had
an adverse event signal in the ve system
uh from the very beginning off the
charts and yet there is no interest in
investigating what it is made of so that
has left people to do so
in uh in environments outside of
Institutions that are not equipped to do
this analysis properly obviously there
are plenty of people who are just
looking to make a buck hopping on a uh a
resonant uh thread so what what do you
expect this is why you need institutions
and it's why uh those who allowed those
institutions to have become corrupted uh
have put us in so much Jeopardy but um
you know personally I do think there's a
pattern of Turbo cancers do I know that
no because we're in an environment in
which this will of course be politicized
but it does appear to be that lots of
people who didn't have cancers or had
cancer in remission uh are suddenly
facing very uh aggressive tumors
um you know that could be about
something else of course but um I think
there's a reason uh to guess that is
associated temporarily there is a reason
to Guess that it's associated with the
vaccine campaign so I don't know how to
handle this I what I want though is
humility we need humility on this not
the kind of certainty of it's absolutely
clear-cut to get vaccinated it's
absolutely true that miscarriages and
turboc Cancers and dementia and all
these things are related to the like
like we don't want to fall that same
trap of blaming everything on the
vaccine and I don't want to fall into
any trap what I want is a consistent
standard applied to all sides yeah right
if we're going to you know fault people
on the dissident side for errors and
completely fail to notice the consistent
pattern of Errors coming out of the CDC
the consistent pattern of Errors coming
from Eric toppel right the consistent
pattern of Errors from from Peter hotz
you you can find a great substack
article on vanai pad's substack of like
20 different mistakes Eric toppel made
over the past year interpreting studies
or like 10 or 10 or 20 big mistakes and
it's like why are we why would we ever
trust this guy anyway right so just you
know the answer
is all of this is possible because of
double standards right and you know
they're going to hold the dissidents to
an impossibly high standard and they're
going to hold the CDC and Eric toppel to
no standard whatsoever
that's not the way to do this the way to
do this is to figure out what standard
we are going to apply and apply it
universally and then do a proper
analysis exactly the kind of thing that
a functioning institution would do and
we have no functioning institution so um
in in
essence those who were
either
[Music]
um deaf to the growing problem of
capture or Worse corrupt and thought
they were would benefit from that
capture have left us in this vulnerable
position so this belongs on their B and
in terms of Solutions in some ways it's
kind of simple and cor correct me if you
feel like this is naive but if putting
aside politics like someone like Ron
DeSantis and the way Dr Joseph laipo in
Florida have handled coid they're
recommending against the new booster
shot and they earlier on recommended
against particularly for younger men and
they've done some good research on this
it's like desandis has talked about like
if he were to get into office he would
put someone like J bataria as head of
CDC like again putting aside politics or
whatever but it's like I could very
easily see someone else in power
Republican or Democrat or
independent appointing someone else as
the head of CDC cleaning house having
people like Dr Tracy Beth hog and Marty
McCary in the FDA and the CDC who are
honest about which medications and
pharmaceuticals we should take it's like
suddenly like that I feel could very
easily be a clear path out of this where
I don't know why that's not being talked
about enough and said we're only
focusing on misinformation it's like if
we can reform these institutions and put
people in power that we actually trust
and you can look at again Florida as a
perfect example of that where you have
Dr lpo leading the state in a way that I
think has been quite impressive and and
remarkable it's like we can do this we
can do what Florida did and respond to
Public Health in that way and have the
right people in charge would you agree I
agree
that we have to make that attempt but
what I want you to understand is you are
talking
about hundreds of billions of dollars at
stake at a bare minimum the cleaning of
house would result in hundreds of
billions of dollars that would not be
makeable by Pharma and that's just one
of the constituencies the obvious one so
in light
of a loss of hundreds of billions of
dollars how much will they spend to
prevent that cleaning of
house that's that's the point so um it
is not as simple of as hey let's get
some good people in there and let him do
the right thing because the force that
will resist that right thing is almost
unimaginably powerful again I don't
think we have a choice I think this is
the best shot we've got M and it's not
just Ronda sanis I think Ronda sandis uh
is an excellent uh Exemplar of how they
should be
addressed but I also think Bobby Kennedy
represents um an excellent potential for
us rescuing our system as good as we've
got
and I just don't want any of us to be
naive about the forces that will be
arrayed against anything that poses a
credible threat to the illegitimate
access that these people have carved out
for themselves right yeah no I yeah I I
think I agree with that but like you
said I think that's our best attempt so
let's hope 2024 comes around we have
some ideal candidates challenging the
Biden Administration and whether that's
VC or RFK or DeSantis or whoever um I
I'm definitely not interested in another
Trump presidency I think that be far too
much chaos and just complete ization of
the process you saw Trump operation warp
speed the best vaccine we've ever seen
and they've saved this many lives it's
like complete politics whereas I feel
like other other people could be far
more principled um on this front so I
look forward to seeing how 2024 uh plays
out but regardless of the outcome we
should be thankful for substack we
should have gratitude for podcasts
Rumble these platforms Joe Rogan's
podcast no one's saying anyone's perfect
here or that there's that we're
everyone's 100% right on everything it's
like in light of all of the
misinformation put out by public health
and the fact that we have free platforms
like substack that won't censor it's
it's it's it's quite incredible the
amount of effort that independent voices
have put out there in response to this
coordinated campaign to push dangerous
vaccines on especially young and healthy
people which I've been railing about for
a couple years so I I'm I'm thankful for
you know such platforms and I I I I hope
it's not on the part of you know RAV
aora and you know Joe Rogan and people
on substack people like yourself for us
to continue to have to do this thing for
the next 10 years where we can't ever
trust the CDC and the FDA anymore and
the next the next pandemic or the next
medication or the next Health crisis
just continually we have to keep on
factchecking them and proving that
they're wrong like I hope we can get to
um a different place but like you said
the the layers of corruption run so deep
and with respect to where I'm going in
the future I'm going to be doing more
and more coverage and exposes of the
similar patterns and practices when it
comes to things like mental health which
I'm very very interested in the way
problems like ADHD and depression and
anxiety increasingly with Gen Z is being
treated with Band-Aid solutions that are
blunt pharmaceutical tools that don't
actually address some of the root causes
um of these problems like not actually
looking at things like intergenerational
trauma and learn behaviors but just
popping a pill in the same way that we
treated coid like we didn't look at the
Obesity epidemic and the problem of
metabolic disease and the way we handle
our food and which things we consume and
our increasingly sedentary Behavior
instead we just said get these mRNA
shots not looking at vitamin D and
exercise and all these things it's like
this kind of aligns with my broader
spiritual kind of explorations of how
our society is falling under this
reductionistic heavy simplistic
pharmaceutical model of giving things
these Band-Aid pharmaceutical Solutions
when it comes to our health but actually
failing to recognize the complexity of
us as human beings in an increasingly
corporate and pharmaceutical heavy
environment where these consensus get
erected on complex scientific topics and
the actual complexity on the matter gets
completely obscured and so here we are
on substack and Rumble trying to make
sense of these things yeah well I I
agree with that I think we are going to
have to uh to the extent that there is
an electoral solution here we are going
to have to make it happen which means we
have to be ready to fight for somebody
who will actually advocate for us and
who can stare down uh the forces that
will be arrayed against them and are
arrayed against
us Project Unity Unity
202 some sort of some sort of unity 2024
sure um well RAV Aurora it's been a
pleasure um let us point out that people
can find you on substack at illusion of
consensus they can also find you on
Twitter what's your handle uh ravor one
on Twitter uh the illusion of consensus
on substack I uh encourage people to
follow there that appears to be the only
kind of unfiltered uncensored Channel
that I can freely put out my content and
um I would you know greatly appreciate
um you know people if they want to
support us they can become paid
subscribers if they want to but that
appears to be the only kind of major
Channel both for Jay and I but for my
independent journalism to thrive with
direct reader support instead of relying
on big newspapers where there's just too
much suppression too much stifling too
much censorship and too much
narrativizing espe you know even in
alternative places as we've learned
places that again were you took the
heretical or dissident line on social
justice but on vaccines for some reason
just put their fingers in their ears and
just defaulted to the CDC it's it's been
quite remarkable so anyway people can
find me on on substack where I'm going
to be doing more and more explorations
of the way big Pharma misinforms us and
puts us in danger and takes us away from
living truly happy fulfilling life that
are addressing our core problems when it
comes to depression ADHD anxiety Etc
there there's a lot more corruption that
meets the eye and I'm at least grateful
that the coid pandemic has sort of put a
shining light on the inner Machinery of
how the sausage gets made and just how
much False Consensus and illusion of
consensus there is on these topics yep
well we're going to have to uh recapture
our system and rebuild the
institutions and uh to that end RAV I
really appreciate your work and thanks
for joining me on Darkhorse yeah thanks
Brett appreciate it be
[Music]
well